r comment ça c'est mal joué on a
découvert le colis dont on sait qu on
sait comment ils et comment
voilà quelle couleur il est qu'on a
découvert le mal les brèches du mal
[Musique]
nous allons annoncer quelque chose de
fantastique ce sont les mots de donald
trump qui va dévoiler dans la soirée le
nom de son candidat à la cour suprême et
il devrait nommer à me connaît par est
une magistrate connu pour ses
convictions religieuses traditionalistes
le président qui a engagé ce processus
au pas de course pour pouvoir ancrer
durablement cette plus haute juridiction
américaine dans le conservatisme et
juges de la cour suprême sont nommés à
vie aux etats unis
[Musique]
le premier ministre désigné renonce à
former un gouvernement au liban mustapha
a dit bhl jette l'épongé après plusieurs
semaines de tractations les divergences
sur l'attribution des portefeuilles
ministériels persiste alors que les
partis politiques s'étaient engagées
auprès d'emmanuel macro à former un
cabinet sous deux semaines un nouveau
gouvernement doit remplacer celui qui a
démissionné le 4 août dernier après la
gigantesque explosion au port de
beyrouth
la tentation de la désobéissance civile
à à marseille à quelques heures de la
fermeture des restaurants et des bars
malgré un sursis les professionnels
devront fermer leur établissement dès
demain soir pour une durée d'au moins
une semaine la colère et le désarroi
d'un secteur déjà durement éprouvé par
la crise
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue sur rt france est la
une de l'actualité ce samedi l'annnonce
de donald trump ce soir le chef de la
maison blanche va révéler le nom de son
choix à la cour suprême
il pourrait s'agir d' amicone barrette
c'est une magistrate conservatrice connu
pour ses convictions religieuses
traditionalistes le président qui vote
qui veut aller vite à moins de 40 jours
de l'élection présidentielle
si ce choix est validée par le sénat
cela devrait ancrer durablement la plus
haute juridiction américaine dans le
conservatisme puisque les juges ils sont
nommés à vie
walid bennani ce jeudi à washington sur
les marches de la cour suprême
donald trump se recueille devant le
cercueil de l'icône démocrate ruth bader
ginsburg avait confond des remontrances
votre image ou traduisez voter contre
lui
plusieurs opposants ont fait le
déplacement pour exhorter également le
président américain a honoré le souhait
de l'une des figures de la lutte pour
l'égalité homme femme est décédée
vendredi 18 septembre à l'âge de 87 ans
la juge démocrate aurait confié à sa
petite fille avant de mourir ne pas
vouloir être remplacé avant qu'un
nouveau président soit investie en
janvier prochain
je pense que c'était juste des champs
politique on pouvait à peine les
entendre nous on était quelqu'un a dit
qu'il y avait des slogans scandés
mais il était juste à côté des médias
mais on ne pouvait vraiment pas on
entendait à peine on a entendu un bruit
mais il n'était pas très fort elle
tirait ceci je pense que samedi après
midi à 17 heures ce sera un jour très
important dans l'histoire de notre pays
je pense que ce sera un jour vraiment
monumental un très bon choix
une décision stratégique pour le
milliardaire républicain à 38 jours de
l'élection présidentielle selon les
grands médias américain donald trump
aurait choisi la magistrate
emiko nibards est catholique pratiquante
de 48 ans mère de sept enfants est
opposé notamment à l'avortement un
signal fort en direction de l'électorat
religieux conservateur soutient il y a
quatre ans de l'actuel président
américain à notre nom circule celui de
barbara l'agoa
né en floride est d'origine cubaine de
la trup j'aurais alors la carte
hispanique dans cet état du sud souvent
jugé décisif pour remporter une élection
présidentielle nous allons nommer le
candidat qui espérons le sera sur ce
tribunal pendant 50 ans
[Applaudissements]
la seule chose dont je suis sûr c'est
que ce sera une femme est ce que cela
vous convient elle si quelqu'un une
objection à cela s'il vous plaît lever
la main
il ya beaucoup de l'ach ici regardez
vous messieurs je ne vois pas il n'y a
pas un seul homme ici qui ait le courage
de lever la main pas un seul les neuf
juges qui composent la cour suprême des
etats unis sont nommés par le président
et confirmés à leur poste elle vit par
le sénat sur les huit membres actuels
cinq ont été nommés par des présidents
républicains dans deux par donald trump
et 3 par des démocrates
avec cette nouvelle nomination la haute
juridiction qui arbitre les grands
débats de la société américaine comme
l'avortement le port d'armes ou encore
la peine de mort s'annonce plus que
jamais conservatrice le sénat devra donc
entériné dans les prochaines semaines ce
choix décisif un sénat à majorité
républicaine et quel que soit le nom
donné ce soir par donald trump il faudra
attendre l'audition du candidat puis sa
validation par les sénateurs
républicains
voyez l'analyse de laurence laurent
cesaris il est professeur d'histoire
contemporaine et spécialiste des états
unis trump a dit je veux le juge avant
avant novembre à cause de l'élection et
cela pour une raison simple c'est que on
s'attend à ce que l'élection serait très
contesté vous avez vu que depuis
plusieurs mois trump jette la suspicion
sur la régularité des votes par
correspondance qui seront bien sûr
nombreux à cause de la deûle à s'élever
19,7 avait donc on peut s'attendre à
beaucoup plus simple élection serrée et
il y aura beaucoup de recours de la part
des républicains
donc il est possible que une fois les
recours devant les cour suprême des 50
états épuisé il y ait au titre du 14e ou
du 15 ème amendement un recours devant
la cour suprême comme ça a été le cas en
2000 avec l'élection de goût de mouches
3 conjugaux le liban toujours sans
gouvernement malgré les appels répétés
de la france le premier ministre par
intérim a annoncé qu'il abandonnait
après des semaines de tractations
mustapha adib a démissionné ce matin au
cours d'une brève allocution devant la
presse à la télévision il s'est excusé
auprès des libanais de ne pas pouvoir
poursuivre cette mission
principal point de blocage le poste clé
de ministre des finances que le tandem
hezbollah amal ne veut pas lâcher
écoutez le premier ministre désigné
démissionnaire alors que les efforts
pour former un gouvernement atteignez
les dernières étapes
je me suis rendu compte que l'accord sur
lequel j'ai accepté cette mission
nationale pendant cette période
difficile de l'histoire du liban
n'existe plus de plus la ligne
gouvernementale avec les spécificités
que j'ai mise a échoué je tiens à
l'unité nationale fondée sur la
constitution et sa crédibilité
je m'excuse de ne pas pouvoir poursuivre
la tâche de former ce gouvernement en
août à bahreïn où ma tâche qu'il est
comme à l'elysée qui a pourtant
multiplié les contacts téléphoniques ces
derniers jours avec beyrouth et ne cache
pas ce soir son irritation regardez
c'est une trahison collective des partis
libanais estime-t-on dans l'entourage
des manuels macron il est indispensable
d'avoir un gouvernement capable de
recevoir l'aide internationale donc la
france ne lâchera pas le liban le
président lui s'exprimera le moment venu
le président emmanuel macron qui devrait
s'exprimer dimanche soir sur cette
question voyez ce qu'on dit joseph
moukarzel il est député suppléant des
français de l'étranger
tout allait bien au début mais il ya eu
des conditions et des conditions en
baisse et genre elle est l'objet
qui est un geek du parlement a décidé
qu'il devait lui-même nommé des
ministres à la base l'accord était que
personne ne nomme des ministres
ils ont plié comme alibi que les
premiers ministres inite les anciens
premiers ministres unis c'est eux qui
dictaient à mustapha team de votre
volonté alors pourquoi c'est d'un côté
donc savez c'était complexe au liban il
ya plusieurs communautés j'accumule
athées se plonge dans son camp et c'est
le franchement a fait que moussa va
vivre ne pouvait pas faire le
gouvernement qui pourrait sauver le
liban actuellement parce qu'il dit qu'il
allait retourner à temps à cause de
conditions probablement qui est proche
de l'ancien gouvernement sortant qui
viennent vernement manipuler ou gérés
par les forces politiques actuel et en
côte d'ivoire la cour africaine des
droits de l'homme donne raison à laurent
gbagbo l'ancien président dont la
candidature a été invalidée la semaine
dernière elle demande en conséquence la
réhabilitation pour la sa réhabilitation
pour la présidentielle du 31 octobre est
l'ancien chef d'état qui était qui est
actuellement exilé en belgique a été
acquitté en première instance des crimes
contre l'humanité qui pesait contre lui
par la cour pénale internationale de la
haye il attend maintenant un éventuel
procès en appel voyez ce qu'en dit
ludovic emmanuelli président de l'ol
j'ai croissance peas et expert en
relations entre l'afrique et l'europe
concernant la décision qui a été pris
par la cour la cour africaine
c'est fabuleux c'est fabuleux parce que
les africains les institutions
africaines assume complètement ce genre
de choses et ne délaisse pas ne l'aide
pas leur ce genre de décision aux autres
institutions internationales donc c'est
déjà une très bonne chose
ensuite est-ce que la côte d'ivoire
visiblement le président actuel n'a pas
très envie d'avoir un concurrent
supplémentaire et donc fait sera en
sorte que
son ex concurrent le président gbagbo
donc ne soit pas présent il ya quatre
présidents qui se présentent
actuellement qu'enfin quatre potentiels
dont lui laurent gbagbo peut être un
obstacle ou alors ça dépend comment il
la joue il peut essayer de le faire
venir par la suite ou ajournées des
élections les les faire se prolonger ce
projet dans un temps plus tard par
stratégie politique à marseille et dans
la métropole plus que quelques heures
pour profiter des bars et des
restaurants demain ils devront fermer
pour au moins une semaine et hier ils
ont manifesté vous ne voyez les
marseillais par centaines devant la
chambre de commerce pour protester
contre cette mesure imposée par le
gouvernement
la tentation de la désobéissance civile
est grande
voyez la colère et le désarroi de ces
professionnels d'un secteur déjà
durement éprouvé par la crise
on subit on ne peut pas faire on ne peut
pas faire autrement
si vous me posez la question êtes vous
pour ou contre je vais te contre voilà
mais après bon c'est vrai que quand on
voit des établissements surtout des
grosses des gros établissements où il
n'y a pas ou il ya aucune distance de
respect de respectabilité où vous voyez
qu'ils n'ont pas de masque il n'y a pas
de gel sur les tables mais si vous voyez
chez nous bon ben voilà
chaque tablette équipée on a du gel on
nettoie nos plateaux chaque fois je veux
dire on essaie de tenir vraiment une
grosse une grosse hygiène voyez pour
pouvoir pouvoir contrer cette fermeture
sachant qu'on est on va dire encore
relativement jeune forcément ça nous
soulevons fait un bail a pas d'autre mot
quoi c'est on est vraiment dégoûté quoi
surtout que ça dure quoi deux semaines
minimum
donc ouais pendant deux semaines en
faire on va faire quoi parce que du coup
on va être obligé de faire des soirées
en appartement ce qui n'a aucune logique
par rapport à cette règle parce que du
coup on sera encore plus nombreux et
encore plus serré et
mais dans des dans des endroits encore
plus clos quoi que dans des restaurants
ou dans des bars donc ça a vraiment pas
de chance mais on fait le point sur la
situation générale de la progression du
virus en france selon santé publique
france plus de 14000 personnes ont été
détectés positive au qu'ovide 19 au
cours de ces dernières 24 heures trente
neuf personnes sont décédées à l'hôpital
et selon plusieurs scientifiques
européens il pourrait y avoir un nouveau
pic épidémique le mois prochain avant un
recul en novembre
l'information est basée sur les taux
d'infection et les déplacements intra
européen
sachez aussi que l' oms dit redouter un
doublement du nombre de morts dans les
prochains mois voyez ce qu'en dit jérôme
marty un médecin et président du
syndicat de l'union française pour une
médecine libre il faut faire attention
aux principes de prévisions vous savez
on connaît le principe de précaution et
puis là maintenant apparaît de plus en
plus le principe de prévisions or c'est
tellement plurifactoriels il ya
tellement de choses qui rentrent en
ligne de compte qu'il est extrêmement
difficile de faire des prévisions
alors évidemment la période de noël est
dangereuse parce que c'est la période où
on se réunit où il ya beaucoup de
croiser de population c'est d'ailleurs
pour ça que cette période-là en général
la gastroentérite qui et manu portet
explose parce que les gens se font la
bise se croisent etc mais mais mais
qu'est ce qui va arriver d'ici là noël
noël vous savez à l'échelon de serre à
l'échelle de cette maladie c'est très
loin
donc c'est très difficile de faire des
projections encore une fois reste au
factuel regardons ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui retourne retournant nous
regardons ce qu'il s'est passé et à
partir de là voyons si oui ou non la
maladie progresse mais regardez à deux
mois trois mois c'est extrêmement
difficile
on reste en france avec la colère des
normands un an après l'incendié qui a
ravagé l'usiné de lubrizol plusieurs
manifestations vous le voyez ont été
organisés en france où le slogan est à
coupable lubrizol complices plusieurs
collectifs qui entendent ainsi maintenir
la pression sur l'état et continuer le
combat judiciaire afin de traduire les
responsables devant la justice
ils étaient plusieurs centaines vous le
voyez à rouen où les habitants ne
connaissent toujours pas la nature des
produits qui ont brûlé le 26 septembre
dernier dans le cortège de rouen il y
avait également plusieurs élus locaux
qui ont défilé aux côtés des
manifestants
les précisions sur place de notre
reporter l'île afin amouzou ils étaient
plusieurs centaines de personnes à
s'être donnés rendez vous devant l'
usine lubrizol peu après 13 heures à
l'occasion du premier anniversaire de
cette catastrophe parmi et les
manifestants aussi bien des responsables
politiques des représentants syndicaux
mais surtout des membres d'associations
de victimes pour qui il était important
de venir aujourd'hui exprimer leurs
traumatismes je me propose de les
écouter c'est important c'était crucial
d'être là effectivement un an après la
catastrophe parce que 2 face aux
sessions elle s'est montée à la campagne
beaucoup focalisé effectivement sauront
ce qui est normal puisque les parties de
10,6 mais faut pas oublier que la
catastrophe du heysel a connu et des
dizaines de milliers d'hectares
jusqu'aux pays bas et tout
particulièrement nos adhérents la
plupart habitent à 30 40 km 50 km de
rond
aucun d'entre eux pensent être entre
guillemets riverains d'une usine seveso
et prendre un jour une marée noire venue
du ciel à côté des riverains des
représentants syndicaux mais aussi des
responsables politiques et qui participe
à pratiquement tout aléa manifestations
qui se tiennent depuis cette catastrophe
et pour qui il était important d'être là
aujourd'hui pour réclamer toute la
transparence sur ce dossier
ça fait un an que la catastrophe de
lubrizol a eu lieu et que nous n'avons
toujours pas la vérité sur les
pollutions qu'ont eu à subir les
riverains et les travailleurs de cette
usine et lubrizol c'est un des 1089
accident industriel qu'on a par an donc
c'est un parmi tant d'autres on en a
trois par jour en france et il faut
maintenant tirer les leçons de ces
crises lundi c'était les 19 heures de la
catastrophe d'azf nous sommes à un mois
et demi de la catastrophe de beyrouth
maintenant il faut que l'état prenne ses
responsabilités et mettre les moyens
pour minimiser les risques industriels
ceux connus nous faisons absolument pas
aujourd'hui on croit que c'est normal
qu'un an après et encore l'odeur qui a
dans cette ville après que c'est encore
normal qu'un an après il ya une partie
de la population qui soit encore
imprégné par cet honneur est tous assez
par rapport à une simple et unique
logique celle du profit donc on est venu
le dire de la région parisienne auprès
de ce collectif unitaire qui est
extrêmement large sur la ville de dire
un moment donné plus jamais ça mais pour
plus jamais ça ça veut dire que nos vies
c'est avant tout prioritaire avant les
profits cette manifestation s'est
globalement déroulée dans le calme le
cortège s'est dispersé devant le palais
de justice alors un an après cette
catastrophe
l enquête nature pas déterminer les
origines de lens ont dit les deux
société lubrizol est normal normandie
logistique se rejettent la
responsabilité et se livre à une
véritable bataille de communication en
tout cas pour tous les manifestants avec
qui nous avons parlé aujourd'hui il
était important d'être là aujourd'hui
pour réclamer
justice et réclamé que toute la lumière
soit faite sur ce qu'il considère ici
comme l'une des plus graves catastrophes
industrielles de ces trente dernières
années
et voyez ça présent les raisons de la
colère des normands un an après cette
catastrophe trop de questions qui
restent sans réponse nous dit olivier
blond président de l'association respire
très clairement il ya il ya eu une
véritable marée noire qui s'est répandue
dans la ville cesser ces gigantesques
dix mille tonnes d'hydrocarbures qui
partent en fumée c'est c'est vraiment
évidemment un traumatisme et le deuxième
traumatisme c'est ces îles et sanitaires
on sait bien qu'il va y avoir des
conséquences est la question c'est de
justement les mesures et un an après on
a toujours cette inquiétude sans réponse
sur quels sont les risques auxquels ont
été exposés la population quels sont les
produits chimiques qu'ils ont respiré ou
qu'ils ont été confrontés et c'est très
très très inquiétant
ce rassemblement à paris aujourd'hui sur
le site de la centrale à béton de
lafarge dans le 15e arrondissement ils
protestent contre un un projet de
reconstruction et de développement du
site qui aurait selon eux de graves
conséquences écologiques
un site qui est à moins de cinq mètres
de la scène est donc un potentiel danger
pour la faune et la flore dans une zone
en plus inondable et de surcroît classée
rouge dans le plan de prévention des
risques
des représentants de la france insoumise
et d'europe écologie les verts étaient
sur place regarder le gouvernement et la
ville de paris ont décidé de renouveler
la concession est de permettre à lafarge
de multiplier par deux sa production de
béton mais ça veut dire quantité
d'adjuvants chimiques qui vont être
entreposées plus de fioul dans une zone
inondable danse extrêmement dangereux et
en plus on a là des de la haute pression
sur lequel on ne devrait pas construire
donc il ya vraiment un danger potentiel
et surtout on peut se bâtir passer du
béton qui est extrêmement polluant en
ayant recours aux matériaux à biot
sorciers des constructions donc on est
là pour exiger la fermeture de cette
centrale à l'arrêt du projet
développement et qu'enfant il déchire
cas sont écologiques sur le bâtiment
il ya un enjeu
âge heures à protéger notre
environnement on a un gouvernement qui
dit il faut simplifier les démarches
administratives
mais en fait ça conduit à faire prendre
toujours plus de risques à la population
on l'a vu avec l'extension des capacités
de stockage de lubrizol
on l'a vu avec le peu de sanctions qui a
pour cette centrale de béton et c'est
pour ça que nous voulons renforcer les
contrôles en ile de france parce que la
population francilienne est exposée à
des risques majeurs au niveau industriel
est également nous militons pour la
création d'une personnalité juridique
pour les biens communs comme par exemple
pour la scène un mot de l'attak au
hachoir hier à paris près des anciens
locaux de charlie hebdo garde à vue
prolongée pour six des neuf personnes
arrêtées
le principal suspect a prénommé à 10h
dit avoir 18 ans il est né au pakistan
il est arrivé en france il ya deux ans
il dit assumer son acte et affirme avoir
agi pour des raisons politiques après la
republication récente des caricatures de
mahomet ils pensent élite il s'en
prendre à des journaliste de charlie
hebdo
l'homme était connu des services de
police il avait été arrêté dans le métro
parisien en possession d'un tournevis il
a à l'époque était considéré comme
mineur il bénéficiait donc de l'aide
sociale à l'enfance
et même si son statut de mineur n'avait
pas été formellement prouvé
allez on reste en france avec le retour
sur cette polémique polémique après les
mots proférés par jean michel blanquer
sur cette fameuse tenue républicaine
elle a fait beaucoup de buzz sur les
réseaux sociaux qui rit kotick of depuis
le hashtag lundi 14 septembre par lequel
des collégiens et des lycéens
revendiquer le droit de s'habiller comme
ils le souhaitent
on est entré dans un débat houleux et
sans fin sur la manière dont il faudrait
être vêtu à l'école le ministre de
l'éducation nationale jean michel
blanquer a tenté il ya quelques jours de
mettre fin à la discussion
déclarant il est important d'arriver à
l'école dans une tenue correcte cela
relève du bon sens
l'école n'est pas un lieu comme les
autres vous n'allez pas à l'école comme
vous allez à la plage ou en boîte de
nuit
chacun peut comprendre qu'on vient à
l'école habillée d'une façon
républicaine
oui bonjour excusez moi de vous déranger
j'aimerais connaître la définition de
tenues républicaine s'il vous plaît ah
bon adacore d'accord merci
là bas il y en a pas bah oui on n'a pas
en réalité chaque établissement scolaire
à son propre règlement intérieur dans
lequel la question de la tenue peut être
abordé en france il n'existe aucun texte
national qui donne une définition
précise et fixe les règles à part les
lois de 2004 et 2010 qui interdisent de
manifesté ostensiblement dans un
établissement laïc une appartenance
religieuse comme porter le voilà qui
part ou une croix en pendentif
le ministère a tenté de calmer le jeu en
précisant que l'expression de jean
michel blanquer sur la tenue
républicaine ne sous-entend des pas que
ce sont les vêtements qui sont
républicains mais que c'est l'école qui
est républicaine
évidemment aussitôt sur twitter c'est la
récréation
[Musique]
mais alors s'il n'existe aucune
définition concrète comment est ce qu'on
fait en suisse par exemple une
information a récemment fait polémique
parce qu'un établissement scolaire
oblige les élèves dans les tenues sont
jugées inadéquates apporter un long tee
shirt xxl sur lequel il est écrit j'ai
une tenue adéquate
ajoutez à cela des témoignages
hallucinant de collégiennes qui
racontent que leurs professeurs leur a
dit que leur tenue un croc top un pull
col roulé qui laisse apparaître le
nombril déconcentre les garçons et on
nage en plein puritanisme et sexisme il
semblerait que le gouvernement et
certains professeurs et chefs
d'établissement être oublié que
l'adolescence est un match particulier
plus ils vont donner des directives aux
élèves assieds toi la victoire comme ça
va là bas moi ils auront de chance
d'établir ne serait ce qu'une once de
communication avec eux ce n'est pas un
sujet spécifiquement pour les filles
par exemple on ne vient pas au collège
en short sauf pour faire de l'éducation
physique et sportive mais surtout quand
il fait 38 degrés à la mi septembre
on doit faire attention à
l'hypersexualisation qui est une
pression sur nos enfants et adolescents
le vêtement ne doit pas être un facteur
ni de discrimination ni de
stigmatisation alors oui dans les faits
on est d'accord mais en interpellant
publiquement une collégienne de 12 ans
parce qu'elle porte un vêtement qui
laisse apercevoir son nombril en lui
expliquant que cela va des concentrés
son camarade de classe n'est ce pas
hyper sexualisée la question à la quelle
époque pour être en vie comme on dit sur
les réseaux sociaux
allez on termine par cette information l
annonce de nicolas dupont aignan comme
candidat à la présidentielle de 2000 22
le député de l'essonne et président de
debout la france l'a annoncé aujourd'hui
sur une chaîne concurrente il s'était
déjà présenté en 2012 puis en 2010 est
où il avait réuni 4 7 % des voix
puis ils s'étaient ralliés à la
candidate marine le pen au second tour
selon lui les français
ne souhaite pas d'un nouveau duel entre
emmanuel macron et marine le pen lors de
la prochaine présidentielle
voyez ce qu'il a ce qu'il nous dit
justement de ses motivations
la campagne va être très simple quels
sont les défis du pays
premier défi c'est le désordre qui
atteint des proportions incroyables donc
re restaurer l'ordre public
deuxième défi ce sont les
délocalisations c'est la perte d'emploi
de pouvoir d'achat qui met en péril
notre système social donc il faut
relocaliser un million d'emplois et
j'explique comment bien sûr et puis il
ya plus grave encore c'est la crise de
confiance du pays et la crise de
confiance se sera pas un homme
providentiel qui tombera du ciel c'est
de rendre le pouvoir aux français et
notamment le fameux rich
je veux que l'on puisse avoir un
référendum d'initiative citoyens à la
fois au niveau national et à la fois au
niveau local c'est fondamental on ne
redressera pas la france sans les
français et ce programme précis concrets
je suis convaincu qu'il correspond à ce
qu'attendent nos concitoyens semblant il
faut le temps de leur présenter et c'est
la fin de ce journal merci de votre
fidélité
on se retrouve dans 30 minutes pour un
prochain point sur l'information rester
avec nous à l'info est à suivre
également sur notre site internet
rt france point tv et à suivre nos
magazines d'actualité rester avec nous à
tout à l'heure
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
pieds coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la veille mais idée
courageuse des mots qui comptent en soi
vient dé l'union aujourd'hui on a une
gauche extrêmement tous les peu moins de
notre époque sont dans la grande
interview
[Musique]
quelle reprise économique pour l'après
qu'ovide 19
à quoi peut-on s'attendre on a été dans
l'oeil du cyclone cet été en fait ça
fait à peu près de 30 ans que la
croissance structurelle en france baisse
donc elle va continuer à être au mieux
médiocre et au pire catastrophique les
prévisions que peuvent faire le fmi ou
la deutsche bank
c'est des prévisions ou doigt mouillé ça
n'a pas grande valeur si l'état était
capable de relancer l'économie
la france est le pays plus développés du